I was checking out the numbers of the
first month of the david pakman show
youtube channel just in sort of
reviewing what's going on with a variety
of the different platforms that the show
is on this is such a busy time with the
election etcetera the first month we had
900 something views on our channel and i
was just amazed when you look at the
progress over a period of several years
at how far we've come 900 something
views in the entire first month that we
had a youtube channel we are now
averaging five thousand to ten thousand
new subscribers per month to the YouTube
channel and if you compare that to nine
hundred views it is just stunning the
growth that that platform has had for us
we're now at roughly seven million views
per month on the YouTube channel and I'm
coming to you today with peace and love
is the great Ringo Starr has been quoted
as saying to tell you that the immediate
goal for us is to get to 300,000
subscribers and we are rapidly
approaching that milestone and to a
regular view count of 10 million views
per month and then from that point you
know that that's not the end once we get
there then there will just be an even
bigger goal to get to and you will
everybody here we're all preparing for
the slight letdown that there always is
after a big presidential election I was
looking back to our YouTube channel in
the months leading up to the twenty
twelve election starting sort of in July
and then really building in
august-september in October up to and
including most of the month of November
and when January hits it's a bit of a
letdown when you when you look at the
the the fact that interest in what a lot
of your subject matter is has declined
it's not the most exciting time Jason as
i like to say we're really in the
exciting time now but what has persisted
is that the channel continues to grow
and i hope that you will hit that
subscribe button and help us get closer
to 300,000 300,000 subscribers nothing
to sneeze at i have to say no not at all
i think
you know it's pretty simple they just
gotta hit the button subscribe how how
hard is it and to be perfectly honest if
you don't want to get the email updates
when we publish new clips you can
subscribe and just turn off the email
updates I think actually they're off by
default I know a lot of people tell me
you know I hesitate I just manually go
to different YouTube channels each day
because I don't want to be subscribed in
getting an email every time they publish
a video that's an optional feature and I
know many people in our audience like
that and I actually have it turned on
myself so I can sort of see when you
clips are going live uh but that did
they that's a choice you can did this is
a free world little YouTube is very very
libertarian in that you don't have to
have those email updates turned on and I
do want to thank the 200,000 plus
subscribers who have already been part
of the success we've had and welcome
everybody who will no doubt be part of
the climb to 300,000 that we will
hopefully be announcing sooner than
later